also she was like rubbing my foot which  normally doesn't happen to me the most  massages I've not had my foot rubbed  yeah and she just grabs one of my toes  and it's just kind of  I'm like don't do that  the gripper yeah yeah it was just  crossing into a territory right yeah  she's like sorry yeah they grabbed me  first  I look back it's like wrapped around her  fingers  I will do that they got a mind of their  own those boys do what they want your  feet are massaging her hands I simply  just reached down they just grabbed me  it feels really good yeah she's she's  asleep  ah damn it happened again  my damn grippers my grippers they just  know no limits